paolo ha lasciato pensando ecco allora
spiegami come funziona ace di scegliere
il lavoro ai uscito il mio lavoro e
voglio fare quello che consegna le pizze
fattorino da ok ma la mia testa è
piccolissima si striminzita per fa vj
500 soldi cosa vuol dire guidare come è
certo che penso che faccia guidare
proprio la pizza esce dalla ma avreste
dovuto farei il cantiere che lavoro con
suolo giocata gta un sacco ciao bella
ragazza ai più cibo per questa casa
se voi ancora non ho capito chi cambia
lavoravamo investito un fatto che si
cambia beni che deve cambiare lavoro
alla fda c'è anche il coso qua con
preghiere ma c'è ancora la pizza dimaro
nostra fine non è consegnata che
costeggia la pizza consegnata erano
quelle tutta l'asp e mi dice che
consigliano un'altra adesso ecco il più
cibo per questa campagna è chiuso la
porta in faccia persona volesse più bene
col cibo in dubbio entrare ma scusami
questa qui prende la pizza non mi fa
entrare squadrina hai capito che lo sto
andando dalla finestra e impazzire
durassero arrestati guardaci facendo
perché andiamo a lavorare vi prego che
si sta arredando casa il pavimento di
ciottoli ma cosa vuoi
cosa vuoi paolo coscia che è pieno di
soldi via fuori una carta che i soldi mi
ha dato di sé tutto quello che tocca oro
quindi cosa vuol dire ami dei soldi
paolo piras divenne variamo andiamo a
lavorare lavorare che facciamo schifo
sono ma lavorare in pizzeria dove vi
piaceva roja e non vale finché paolo
coscia lavora la microsoft la nostra
pizza è garantita di essere calda e
fresca anche il nostro italiano io ho un
impasto della pizza attaccato alla gamba
l'estintore tirando con il marito dato
io pensavo di avervi basso
la piattaforma faccio così schifo a
lavorare io mi si attacca la pizza
azienda brava a cucinare qualcosa
ok no mi auguro alla fine perché questo
salsiccia a posto fragore la pizza
adesso chiudi chiudi forno dove il
telefono è partita solo vai artena solo
è davvero misto questo è un tapis
roulants allenarsi per una pizza e
l'altra ma io non vedo resterà pizzeria
pero non avremmo preso cura di stefano
spagna ha però mi ha comunque il capino
la sua e questa non ha mai fatto un
incredibile non c'è nulla dentro non
puoi mettere più si fa niente lo sta
facendo sta cuocendo facciamo anche le
lattine e basta ma nessuno vuole una
lancia è una lattina più pizza pizza
fila si stacco cina non sa non sai come
si fanno le pizzelle latina si sta
avvicinando
voglio vedere cosa funzionerà euro di
danni altra grande maestro del forno la
pizza è pronta e c'è la lattina sotto
non prendere l'estintore troppo calda la
pizza la devo sfilato per raffreddare
che aspetta paolo coscia mi dica per
darmi dei soldi o non lasme perché
abbiamo portato vi aspetta il lavorava
la microsoft danni dei soldi e scappa
viene vado se lavorassi avresti state i
soldi invece se solo tirando schiuma
della vittoria dopo la persona anche
quello è un lavoro destino è un lavoro
20 st istinto lista guarda tutti gli
ordini che ci sono queste opere non è
fatta neanche una sorgente di ordini li
sopra 32 limonate 84 salsicce non sarà
quelli sempre a quelli le faccio io le
faccio io
vediamo le faccio una pizza riesce a
farla una vacanza non ha più una
vediamo quindi una palla la prima di
pato mette il sugo togliergli le fragole
però vedi che quali il formaggio e
mettere il formaggio a john all invito
formale dove il formaggio a questo è sì
ora la metti la mano
mettere in forno c del formale dalla lui
tavolo mi hanno pagato
mancava che a me mi hanno pagato dei
soldi per aver fatto casino 165 ritira i
miei soldi allora adesso la pista la
metti nel forno kg il form che però ora
chiudo non l'hai fatto non lo fa era
evitato caso sì ma vado bruciando due
anni perché ce l'avevi sempre quando
serve non ce l'hai non ce l'ho alessia è
morto stesso mamma mia che basta che io
non so cos'è questo doppio tempo che ci
ha scritto non ha la più pallida e le
armi navigato nel forno anch'io triste
perchè questa pizza e tipo fluorescente
chi è che l'ha fatta ragazza e l'hanno
rivela speciale ragazzi queste terme non
funzionano come pensavo aspetta
prenderesti interpreta pendii lo
specchio di una mano grazie
chiudi non lo voglio più vedere chiudi
questa che è andato praticamente aiuto
non lo voglio più vedere cosa faceva
prego usate usate l'estintore se ti
chiudi che grazie pare aveva a che fare
altro lavoro fatemi fare altro lavoro
no non fare altri lavori da bene torno
quindi dagli scatolato riscatto liamo
ecco quando ad arredare la casa è
difficile no cioè io qua ed ai soliti
l'unica che sta compiendo qualcosa
signora concetta che lei pironi soldi
nostra cara in pochi mi faresti bene a
mandarci mai lasciarlo qui dice non
prego per consorziale no che poi mi
bruciano allora portiamola per un altro
lavoro l'unico lavoro che non cantano
una vieni vieni vieni a mettermi
selighini libera.vai mettiti le cose in
testa va così per me ne vado veramente
unica né incastrato nella mia faccia
auguro attacca mamma mia che casino sono
diventato ma voi ve la vedete casi lo
vedo purtroppo anche gli auguro che ti
sta aggrappata in spalla cane incastrato
in faccia e un canguro
io non lo voglio vedere lo stesso
diventato ma che cosa manca non è per
ora i miei brani con kangur
la prima ha rubato scorciatoie non lo so
vado uccidermi con paolo coscia per
paolo ma mio dio amore espiantano ed
eseguirà recapitate anche neanche ad
andare a cena non c'è un lavoro che sa
fare eccome
questo lo sa fare benissimo però è stato
il ponte si è incastrata la macchina ma
ci chiediamo ma come fa ce l'ho fatta
ne ha appena investito ce l'ha fatta
ciao paolo è stato un piacere a sei
morto solo tu sì sono io e lui era detto
paolo era un suicidio di coppia eccoti
fermo per uno dei fiocchi auguro come o
forse no se mi auguro si potevano andare
a recuperare togliti paolo non andare a
recuperare i cani voglio recuperare con
culo paolo togliti è troppo tardi ho mai
lasciato lì dove paolo andiamo a casa
sua adesso mi compri un canguro dammi un
canguro
ma c'è una mattinata chi ha i soldi non
ha i denti era cugino prelazione di
sopra attenzione macchinetta però
guardare la tv da solo finissimo va bene
allora usciamo chi sei febbre bella la
casa non c'è alcuno lato piano bis in
sala per l'altra credo quanto hai
lavorato mio dio ci sto offrendo una
birra guarda ma è un estintore e va bene
come romantico e poetico guardare
l'orizzonte tutti insieme per me era
nelle belle sta facendo volare i
palloncini pony che gira ragazzi questo
è stato è stata bellissima nostra
amicizia però voglio dire voglio
condividerli che per me la vostra
amicizia è stata tanto la mia vita
adesso si lancia ci dobbiamo solo dare
qualche efficacia mi ammazzo azzurra che
saliva in auto in automatico
esatto ho investito salvatore 90
determina sera prende le persone
mi ammazzo con salvatore di no cosa che
fa si è capito che oggi doveva fare il
pizzaiolo nero jolo sfocia in altri
lavori tipo di killer suicida ho trovato
che auguro a questa portata non mi rompe
le balle
ok buon appetito mister è soddisfatto è
andata in faccia la parte che è tre
volte testa perché la pioggia è mia e
dovete andare cosa volete e mia
basta che vedo tutti questa vicini che
se ne approfittano ne mangia la pizza
sulla macchina basta che mai per terra
basta andate via
che fastidio non può mangiare una pizza
in pace vasta paolo coscia in company mi
suicido con la pizza non ha veramente
senso giorgio va bè ragazzi io vi
ringrazio per aver partecipato a questo
video per avermi aiutato a fare le pizze
parlamento che non hai fatto nulla e non
ho fatto nulla per ora l'importante che
mi sono esercitato molte volte e poi o
mantiene adatto è stato molto divertente
quindi ragazzi ringrazio i ragazzi per
aver partecipato a questo video date
loro che hanno in descrizione io come
sempre vi aspettiamo fossimo gli
iscritti al canale schiacciata anche
alla campanellina che vi arrivano le
notifiche ma come sempre ci vediamo
sto aspettando che si aprisse tutto lo
schermo più inter ci vediamo un po
seguito da ragazzi